هذه غواصه ديميتري دون سكويا الروسيه اكبر
غواصه نوويه تم تصنيعها في العالم روسيا
طورت الغواصه لتكون اله حربيه استراتيجيه
ثقيله حامله للصواريخ العابره للقارات
سلاح البحريه الروسيه ضمها لقوات الاسطول
الشماليه عام
1982 لكنه اخرجها من الخدمه لاحقا وسائل
اعلام روسيه نشرت في ديسمبر عام 2022 الى
ان الغواصه الشهيره ستنهي خدمتها وستغادر
اسطول البحريه الروسيه الا ان وكاله
التصرفيه كشفت ان هذا العملاق لا يزال
موجودا في مركز فويسكا لاصلاح السفن
والغواصات استغلاله في تجربه انواع جديده
من الاسلحه طول الغواصه يبلغ 172 مترا
ويمكنها الغوص لاربع مئه متر وتضم
منظومتها التسليحيه 20 صاروخا بالستيا
وتوربيدات وصواريخ ايجلا صائده الطائرات